este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
square space ya sean páginas web tiendas
online o herramientas de marketing
analíticas square space es la plataforma
todo-en-uno para construir una excelente
presencia online y operar tu negocio y
ahora vamos con el vídeo
seguramente pienses que estas imágenes
son de un paisaje de suiza- o de austria
verdad pues nada de eso este paisaje
pertenece a italia
y seguramente pensarás que estando en
italia la gente que vive por aquí
hablara italiano verdad pues tampoco
estas imágenes son de tirol del sur y
por estas zonas la lengua más común es
el alemán y con culto a él
muchos pensaréis que el idioma que habla
la gente en italia es el italiano pero
la realidad es mucho más compleja el
país de la pizza y rocco siffredi está
lleno de idiomas y dialectos que no
tienen nada que ver entre ellos por
ejemplo el veneciano no se parece en
nada al siciliano es decir que los
contrastes en italia son mucho más
pronunciados de lo que podríamos pensar
[Música]
y lo mismo ocurre con la política os
imagináis que un partido de extrema
izquierda hiciera un gobierno de
coalición con un partido de extrema
derecha por ejemplo a los que nos veis
desde españa os imagináis a box pactando
con podemos
suena un poco raro verdad pues más o
menos eso es lo que ha pasado en italia
no me creéis pues atentos al vídeo de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
italia es un país de contradicciones por
un lado hablamos del país donde está el
vaticano un país que mantiene el respeto
por las tradiciones y el catolicismo por
el otro lado se trata del país que tuvo
a berlusconi de presidente
[Música]
por un lado italia es uno de los países
más sobre regulados de toda europa por
el otro italia es uno de los países
europeos con más peso de la economía
sumergida pero sin duda alguna la mayor
contradicción de italia es su actual
gobierno una coalición de extrema
derecha y extrema izquierda y ya sé lo
que me vais a decir muchos a ver fonseca
que el movimiento cinco estrellas no es
exactamente un partido de izquierdas y
tenéis razón sería un error decir que el
movimiento cinco estrellas es el
equivalente italiano a podemos por
ejemplo pero tiene más cosas en común de
lo que podríamos imaginar
para empezar también son un partido que
se presenta como una fuerza contra el
establishment proponen cosas como una
renta básica para las clases más bajas y
su organización interna se basa en un
sistema asambleario es más al igual que
podemos en sus inicios el movimiento 5
estrellas también propone reducir el
salario de los políticos para que puedan
empatizar realmente con la clase
trabajadora
[Música]
y lo mismo ocurre con lega es un partido
de derechas como pueda serlo box en
españa pues no exactamente ahora bien
también coinciden en muchas propuestas
como el rechazo a los inmigrantes o el
nacionalismo y esto no es lo más
divertido de todo podríamos decir que el
ega es una contradicción en sí mismo
ahora mismo defienden el orgullo de ser
italiano pero en sus comienzos eran un
partido regionalista que quería
separarse de italia por seguir con la
comparación con la política española
sería algo así como si joaquín torras se
levantará un día y se convirtiera en
santiago abascal y ya sé lo que os
preguntaréis ahora porque le prestamos
tanta atención a italia
[Música]
pues veréis lo primero es que italia es
la tercera economía de la eurozona y
resulta que tienen la peor recesión de
toda europa si italia está en crisis es
posible que toda europa sufra los
efectos pero no sólo eso esta extraña
pareja' que el gobierno italia podría
sentar un precedente para otros países
la política y las ideologías están
cambiando y muchas fórmulas que antes
eran impensables
ahora están gobernando países
[Aplausos]
y no creáis que hablo solamente de
italia por ejemplo en grecia syriza que
es un partido muy de izquierdas llego al
gobierno de la mano de anel que es un
partido muy de derechas y algo parecido
ocurre en república checa donde los
comunistas están en coalición con un
partido antiinmigración y un partido
liberal es esto posible pues parece ser
que si hace diez años nadie se le
ocurriría una fórmula de gobierno
semejante pero las cosas están cambiando
mucho y están cambiando en todas partes
así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es cómo es posible que dos partidos
políticos que en principio son tan
antagónicos terminen gobernando juntos
puede funcionar esta fórmula para sacar
a italia de la crisis hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
de la liga norte a la liga como decíamos
antes italia es un país con más de 34
idiomas y dialectos distintos y las
diferencias no terminan aquí en la
economía pasa más o menos lo mismo para
que os hagáis una idea el sur de italia
tiene una tasa de desempleo de casi el
20%
[Música]
hace pocos años era normal en sicilia
tener cortes de agua a diario y la mayor
parte de la gente trabaja en la
agricultura por salarios bastante bajos
en otras palabras que es una zona
relativamente pobre sin embargo el norte
de italia es un país distinto
[Música]
hablamos del lugar donde nacieron los
ferrari y los lamborghini ciudades como
milán son conocidas en todo el mundo por
la moda la industria y por tener un
nivel de vida comparable con el de las
zonas más ricas de alemania por supuesto
que su tasa de desempleo no llega ni a
un tercio de la de sus vecinos del sur y
la renta per cápita es casi el doble
pues bien esta brecha entre el norte y
el sur es lo que inspiró la creación de
la liga norte en los años 90 su fundador
fue este señor que veis en la pantalla
que se llama umberto bossi en un
principio bossi quería que su región
-claro mardy a que por cierto es donde
está mi land fuera un país independiente
de italia pero un buen día
este señor se levantó por la mañana y
dijo y si nos juntáramos varios partidos
regionalistas y creamos la madre de
todos los partidos separatistas
[Música]
y de acá que acabo de tener
y así es como nació la liga norte una
formación con un único objetivo romper
italia en dos mitades y digo su único
objetivo porque en el resto de temas
tenían división de opiniones había gente
de izquierdas y de derechas lo único que
tenían todos en común era el odio a
italia y el amor por este nuevo país que
querían crear que se llamaba padania por
supuesto como todo movimiento
separatista los paganos también
reivindicaban sus diferencias culturales
pero en este caso su discurso se
centraba más en la economía
umberto bossi decía que roma estaba
robando a las regiones del norte para
dárselo a las del sur y creerme su odio
italia haría que el mismísimo puigdemont
pareciera bertín osborne no me creéis
pues atentos
cada vez que veo la bandera italiana me
entran ganas de art utilizo la tricolor
para limpiarme el culo
umberto bossi es más por seguir con el
paralelismo el señor bosch y también
hizo una declaración unilateral de
independencia de su país
pagán ya en el año 1996 y oración
e independencia
es obra mixta de la pantalla
pero por muy separatistas que fueran la
liga norte seguía siendo un partido
italiano y eso significa que tenían que
jugar con las reglas italianas y
presentarse a las elecciones al
parlamento italiano así que para
expandir su influencia
umberto bossi y su liga norte se
convirtieron en uno de los principales
aliados de los gobiernos de berlusconi y
creedme esta alianza les vino de perlas
de repente los votantes de la liga norte
veían como su voto era muy útil a pesar
de ser un partido regional tenían el
suficiente capital político a nivel
nacional como para poder conseguir un
montón de beneficios para sus regiones
[Música]
despierta padania con la liga norte en
contra de los ladrones de roma' pero por
muy influyentes que fueran a duras penas
pasaban del 8% de los votos es decir que
dentro del contexto italiano y ganar te
seguía siendo un partido pequeño sin
embargo todo esto cambió en el año 2012
en este momento es cuando umberto bossi
sufrió un infarto cerebral y le sucedió
este señor que veis en la pantalla
matteo salvini
ah
salvini venía con una agenda llena de
cambios de entrada a cambio el nombre
del partido que pasó de llamarse lega
nord alega a secas todo esto era mucho
más que un cambio cosmético de repente
el enemigo dejaron de ser los ladrones
de roma para ser los inmigrantes
[Música]
más inmigrantes significa más criminales
salvini está trabajando en un plan de
repatriación y os preguntaréis qué pasó
con todo ese sentimiento anti italiano
no se supone que roma era el mayor
enemigo de los paganos pues como diría
mi querida amiga ter la liga norte hizo
un plot twist en toda regla
levanta la cabeza italia estoy orgulloso
de ser italiano somos el mejor país del
mundo y sólo necesitamos un poco de
trabajo y algo menos de impuestos
matteo salvini ala como queráis de
repente la liga podía buscar votos en
toda italia tanto en el norte como en el
sur y ampliar el mercado siempre tiene
sus ventajas porque si pensabais que
nadie te va a tomar en serio si cambias
tus principios fundamentales de un día
para otro o se equivocan vais
[Música]
victoria de la liga en las elecciones
italianas los tiempos están cambiando
pero si todavía nos ha volado la cabeza
esperar a ver el siguiente actor de esta
historia la izquierda populista italiana
ahora mismo los vamos a conocer
el gran chiste en el año 2009 italia
estaba en mitad de una crisis enorme la
unión europea quería que hicieran
recortes de presupuesto y el gobierno de
berlusconi estaba en su peor momento
todo este contexto era el caldo de
cultivo perfecto para fundar el
movimiento 5 estrellas durante estos
años un cómico que se llama bp grilo
había empezado una plataforma política a
través de su blog seguro que ni él se
imaginaba y lo que terminaría
convirtiéndose podríamos decir que el
bautismo de fuego de este movimiento fue
en el año 2007 cuando bp di lo organizó
el vãnculo day en bolonia
pues si no lo habéis entendido esto
significa literalmente el día de vete a
tomar por se convirtiera un evento
gigantesco con miles de personas
firmando para cambiar la ley electoral
querían evitar que los imputados
pudieran presentarse a las elecciones
legislativas hasta aquí todo normal pero
la auténtica oportunidad para verlo
llegó unos años más tarde la economía
italiana seguía de mal en peor cada vez
más italianos tenían que hacer más
esfuerzos para llegar a fin de mes y
aquí es cuando italia nombra a su primer
ministro tecnócrata exacto hablamos del
gobierno de mario monti un tecnócrata es
un político que dice no tener ninguna
ideología simplemente se basa en los
conocimientos técnicos
[Música]
sin embargo para muchos italianos monti
no era más que un títere de bruselas que
quería austeridad y recortes y el
partido que mejor capitalizó toda esta
rabia fue el movimiento cinco estrellas
poco a poco este partido ganó más y más
alcaldías y más y más puestos regionales
en las elecciones de 2013 fueron el
segundo partido más votado con más de 8
millones de votos todo esto era casi un
milagro para un partido político tan
joven
los resultados de la selección es enorme
victoria para el movimiento cinco
estrellas euforia en internet por el
primer partido en el congreso de los
diputados como decíamos el movimiento
cinco estrellas empezó como un partido
anti establishment de hecho en un primer
momento muchos analistas en españa' lo
comparaban con podemos sin embargo a
diferencia de podemos
los italianos no tenían una ideología
clara ni una hoja de ruta es más a
diferencia de pablo iglesias
bp grilo se apartó en seguida de la
primera línea política y así es como en
el año 2016 llegó la primera gran
victoria
el movimiento cinco estrellas conquista
roma rey y elegida alcaldesa con el 67%
de los votos es un momento histórico y
todos los romanos han ganado todo esto
significa más expertos más ideólogos y
más analistas que se embarcaron en este
movimiento para darle un corpus
ideológico consistente y así es como
poco a poco la ideología del movimiento
cinco estrellas se fue perfilando su
principal propuesta es la democracia
directa es decir que los ciudadanos
dejen de delegar su poder en
parlamentarios y puedan votar en
referéndum de hecho el movimiento 5
estrellas tiene su propio sistema para
hacer votaciones internas por internet
este sistema se llama ruso y sirve para
que los afiliados puedan discutir ideas
propuestas y aprobar proyectos por
ejemplo en un momento parecía que el
partido iba a adoptar posiciones anti
inmigración el propio pp grilo quería
hacer algo por el estilo y mover el
partido en esa dirección sin embargo hay
que reconocer que la democracia interna
en este partido funciona
[Música]
creel o los votantes registrados del
movimiento cinco estrellas han dicho no
a convertir la inmigración ilegal en
delito pero sin duda alguna el auténtico
cambio en este partido llegó en 2017 con
la llegada de luigi de mayo a la
dirección este es el auténtico artífice
del matrimonio izquierda a derecha que
gobierna italia en estos momentos pero
como ha sido posible algo así pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver pareja liberal hay
una cosa muy importante que tenemos que
entender en italia aquí los partidos
políticos van y vienen como si fueran un
vídeo viral de moda para que os hagáis
una idea desde el año 1946 italia ha
tenido 29 primeros ministros distintos
esto significa que la media de un primer
ministro italiano es de dos años y medio
los partidos prácticamente se crean y se
destruyen
elección tras elección y esto significa
que cada vez que hay unos nuevos
comicios es muy difícil hacer
predicciones por ejemplo en las últimas
elecciones europeas parecía que la
de matteo salvini estaba a punto de
desaparecer unos años después y es uno
de los partidos más votados si hay algo
difícil en esta vida es explicarle un
italiano lo que significa suelo
electoral y por eso en el año 2018 los
partidos más moderados se pegaron un
auténtico batacazo la izquierda moderada
del partido democrático se quedó muy por
debajo de lo que había sido y lo mismo
pasó con el centroderecha de berlusconi
así que los únicos que estaban
dispuestos a hacer una coalición eran
los más populistas el movimiento 5
estrellas y la liga por supuesto cada
uno tiene su propia versión de populismo
y también sus propios feudos cinco
estrellas cosechó casi todos sus votos
en el sur de italia mientras que la liga
por mucho que cambiara de nombre seguía
teniendo casi todo su apoyo en el norte
sin embargo ambos partidos capitalizaron
el voto protesta en otras palabras las
opciones moderadas han perdido el fuelle
en italia ahora lo que antes era
outsider se ha convertido en el nuevo
main
[Música]
elecciones italianas los populistas del
movimiento 5 estrellas y la liga se
disputan el poder pero como os podéis
imaginar este matrimonio no fue tarea
fácil hicieron falta más de 10 semanas
para que se pusieran de acuerdo a fin de
cuentas habían sido adversarios antes de
las elecciones pero por el otro lado
podían sumar una mayoría en ambas
cámaras tanto el congreso como el senado
así que finalmente el movimiento de
cinco estrellas trajo su 32 por ciento
de los votos y la liga su 17 por ciento
y así es como empezó el nuevo gobierno
de italia
[Música]
y diréis de veras son capaces de
entenderse en una coalición quien está
traicionando a sus votantes pues la
respuesta es que por el momento no
parece que tengan grandes problemas es
más cada uno a su manera está cuidando a
sus votantes salvini está intentando por
todos los medios sacar leyes contra la
inmigración y también quiere poner un
impuesto lineal del 15% para empresas e
individuos los expertos dicen que esta
reforma fiscal dejaría las arcas
italianas con 80.000 millones de euros
menos cada año
sin embargo luigi de mayo parece
aceptarlo ahora bien a cambio de poder
plantear su reforma de renta básica que
según las estimaciones esta renta básica
costaría 17.000 millones de euros y si
lo sé desde el punto de vista del
cálculo económico no funciona pero desde
el punto de vista del cálculo político
ya lo creo que funciona básicamente
podríamos decir que este gobierno es
como una pareja abierta están juntos
pero a la vez cada uno puede tener otras
parejas en otras palabras aunque estén
en coalición cada uno sigue intentando
prepararse para ganar más votos en las
próximas elecciones y lo cierto es que
no parece que vaya a ser tarea fácil
la 'dolce vita' parece a punto de
desaparecer de nuevo mientras italia
vuelve a la recesión
exacto italia está en plena recesión es
más justo en el momento en el que el
primer ministro giuseppe conte dijo que
italia estaba a punto de tener un
milagro económico boom el pib italiano
bajaba en un 0,2 por ciento en 2018
por el momento el gobierno dice que todo
esto se debe a historia del ciclo
económico europeo que bueno que ya se
sabe que si quieres te lo miro lo cierto
es que en el resto de países europeos
siguen creciendo mientras italia decrece
a eso se le llama tener problemas y
mientras tanto todas estas políticas de
gasto van a dar más de un dolor de
cabeza a los europeos pero todo esto es
tema para otros vídeos porque ahora la
pregunta es creéis que sería posible una
alianza similar en vuestro país porque
sí y por qué no podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios pero sabéis
qué es lo que le vendría muy bien tanto
a los del movimiento cinco estrellas
como a los de la liga pues exactamente
hacerse una página web en square space
mirad es súper fácil ya está si quieren
pueden tener su propia tienda online
para vender merchandising y también a ti
que me estás viendo desde el móvil o
desde el ordenador quieres mejorar tu
presencia online pues entra en space
quienes tengas la necesidad de tener una
página web donde la gente pueda
encontrarte o tal vez acabas de crear tu
propio negocio y necesitas empezar a
desarrollar tu presencia online o tu
propia tienda pues bien todo esto es
posible gracias a space
en square space encontrarás plantillas
para tu web con diseños increíbles y si
a lo mejor no te interesan las
plantillas tienes el talento y la
creatividad para diseñar tú mismo tu
propia página web desde cero también
puedes hacerlo por tu cuenta sin
plantillas school space hace súper fácil
el poder construir un espacio que
resulte alucinante
square space también puedes registrar un
dominio nuevo o mover uno que ya tengas
el proceso no podía ser más sencillo
pero oye si te surge cualquier duda
square space ofrece un servicio de
atención al cliente 24 horas donde
siempre puedes encontrar a alguien que
te pueda ayudar así que lo dicho así que
lo dicho si quieres tener tu propio
espacio tu propia tienda online o lo que
sea
hazlo realidad con square space vete a
square space.com para una prueba
gratuita y cuando lo tengas todo listo
te vas a square space.com
visual polítiques
para ahorrarte un 10% al adquirir tu
primer website o dominio y como siempre
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]